the history of Portugal is along an
interesting one its influence is
widespread and not only did it affect
the rest of the European continent but
its sailors bridge the world's oceans
few parts of the world would be the same
were not for Portugal but where did this
nation come from who founded Portugal
and well to put it bluntly
how did Portugal happen in order to find
this out we need to travel back to the
turn of the 12th century when the
Iberian Peninsula looked like this in
the South that was dominated by the arm
or ovid emirate and the majority of the
people in Iberia at this time were
Muslims who had over the centuries
converted from Christianity after the
Islamic conquests of the ape century
whereas in the north Christianity in
jordiz the religion of the small
independent states there and these
northern states were the kingdoms of
Leon Navarre and Aragon as well as the
county of Barcelona and the states were
to put it mildly not exactly keen unless
other neighbors the way they dealt with
these issues was via in-depth
discussions and just kidding crusade
time these Crusades brought the devout
from of the European states to help him
one such man was Henry of Burgundy in
1095 he went south got married to the
king of Castile as illegitimate daughter
and was given the County of Portugal to
rule long story short he died his wife
had an argument with their son and heir
Alphonso war which are Fonzo one he
exiled his mother to a convent and then
ruled as the count of Portugal after
11:28 a short eleven years later our
phones are decided that being a count
wasn't as cool as being a king and so
renounce his fealty to leon there was a
war because obviously which Alfonso won
and after this Portugal became an
independent Kingdom Alfonso was crowned
Alphonso the first also before
continuing the name Portugal derives
from the settlement of porta caeli which
eventually became the city of Porto as
you'll have noticed the fledgling
kingdom of Portugal is quite a bit
smaller than the one we know today and
this is where outside help came in so
the Knights Templar had previously
helped her Fonzo in his war for
independence and they had been
generously rewarded for the help and
Afonso could count on their help in his
plans to 1 preserve his kingdoms
independence and to strengthen it by
expanding southwards and by sheer luck
in 1140 for the Crusader state of Edessa
fell to the seljuqs and so the Pope
doing what medieval popes did best
called for a crusade many asks at the
call and those from these lands rather
than go the overland route opted to sail
around Iberia on their way they stopped
off in Portugal where they met Alfonso
who asked for their help
the Crusaders weren't really interested
in helping at first until Alfonso
sweeten the deal with cash specifically
any in all of the spoils from helping
him take the strategically important
city of Lisbon the Crusaders in the
Portuguese laid siege to Lisbon in 1147
and it wasn't too long before the city
surrendered due to salvation for many
that was enough crusading and whilst a
couple of thousand Crusaders continued
on their way to the Holy Land most
notably the English opted to settle in
Portugal Portugal southward expansion
would continue until its borders reached
this in the 13th century in Lisbon was
made the country's capital
Portugal's place in history had begun I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching but thanks to my
patreon supporters whom you can see on
screen now and with an extra special
thanks to James Bissonnette Ike Danny
Maloney Colin Castleman Marvin Castle
Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white Jordan
long way Chris wicker Gustav Swann
Gareth Turner
Marcus arse nur Maggie pax Kowski David
Silverman
spinning three plates Spencer Lightfoot
Lexi Schwinn Winston k-word Kelly
moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell pass you 19 and Mo